What’s in a name?
And can our names really affect our outcomes
in life?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and have you
ever noticed how we tend to associate certain
names with personalities?
I’m reminded a 30 Rock quote, where Alec
Baldwin’s character points out "There will
never be a president Ashton.”
Which seems probable - but is there any science
behind that?
And can our names really predict our futures?
It’s an interesting question - and there
have been a lot of studies over the years,
trying to figure out how our names affect
our lives.
A recent one, published in the journal Personality
and Individual Differences, looked at over
300 pairs of twins in China, and found that
not only is liking your own name predictive
of your well-being, it’s also determined
in large part, by your genetic and environmental
background.
Another study, published in 2005, found that
boys who were given girl’s names, were more
likely to have behavioral problems, and as
a result - generally do poorer in school.
There have also been a bevy of studies examining
the racial aspects of naming.
A 2004 study in The American Economic Review,
found that job applicants with white-sounding
names, as opposed to characteristically black
names - received 50% more callbacks for interviews
- even if their qualifications were the same.
So often times, it’s more about the stereotypes
of other people, than it is about your actual
name.
There was another study in 2003 on the topic
of racial naming conventions, which argued
that even if stereotypes like that do affect
job callbacks - it’s unlikely they would
make a difference beyond the interview stage,
since our perceptions of people’s names
don’t matter as much, once we’ve personally
met them.
Racial stereotypes aside, though - how does
all of this work?
I mean, it’s our parents who name us, after
all - and history shows that parents tend
to name their kids after people they like.
But is it really just about preference, or
is there some social status at play?
According to social psychologist Martin Skinner,
"The real consequence is not in the actual
name itself, but in the intentions behind
it.”
He says that "Names usually reflect parental
aspirations, so someone who wants their child
to be taken seriously will give them a name
that has weight and is not frivolous - whatever
class they are."
So in a sense, our names reveal more about
our parents, than they do about us.
Here’s a perfect example.
There was a series of studies done in the
mid 1900s, that found that kids with unusual
or uncommon first names were more likely to
experience mental illness, and in particular
- psychosis and neurosis.
Now if we’re operating under the assumption
that those names are a reflection of the psychological
state of their parents, then it’s likely
that the parents chose those names, as a way
of unconsciously signaling that their kids
are peculiar and perhaps even deserving of
ridicule.
If that is the case, then it’s equally as
likely that those parents sent their kids
other negative messages over the years - unconscious
or not - that could’ve led to them developing
a mental illness.
And to look at it from another angle, it’s
also entirely possible that the parents who
gave their kids unusual names, also experienced
similar illnesses, which were then passed
down to their kids through their genes.
Whatever the case may be - it’s generally
agreed that the outcome your name has on your
success levels is pretty negligible.
In the long run, your own personal efforts
can easily outweigh the impact of your name.
What do you guys think?
Do you feel like your name has contributed
to your personality?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below, and as always - thank you guys for
watching!